hey guys Greg Alva here we're shooting
to the camera - we're also live
streaming this right now it's kind of
weird hopping back four three two camera
but if you watch them side by side
eventually we'll make eye contact on
both planets all right here we go John
[Music]
good evening Peter cool you know 500 and
the six possible combinations whoa -
yeah something me when do we move next
mission we'll call you
all right it's not a hunger in scram you
talk way out there yet okay good luck
doing that you don't like I can't deny I
got the extension to shake what's up
guys so here's my report provided I
stuff to a glass that's like school hey
did you do me a favor
I hope this little lady and she bought
me a churro
so the real event just gives it away you
move them working up some bad
[Music]
welcome to crazy dangerous listen Taylor
they're people who handle this okay
can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
[Music]
world's changing boys time we change too
I can't put my god you smashed we gotta
get better at this part of the job dog
lover lovely whoa
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
I'm going what are you hiding Peter
ah
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol because mister
start treating me like a kid you are a
kid you can stop a boss in his bare
hands
[Music]
I got to tell you I'm really liking the
tone
yeah I'm really liking the tone hey I
got a question for you guys on the live
stream really quick should we watch the
international one right now as a
difference is the international one like
any different or is it just the same
damn I'm glad we're stepping on a live
stream right now to ask them these
questions except now yeah a lot of
people are saying it's different see a
lot of people are saying it's different
yeah alright international yeah it's do
I guess we're watching the international
trailer too as well on I've heard it's
dope
dang bro Wow look at that new guy who
said I go oh cool lifted Walsall yeah
happy solution of powerful I don't care
about that please pick up a stern with
these they're table scraps daily
ambassadors at top you got to use this
don't tell you to roll change time you
change too
wait your next mission we'll call it a
little more mentoring if you're real a
sex thank you
it's not a hugging was grabbing the top
away oh okay good luck out there
all your collecting for Avengers battles
and building you crazy weapons this is
my chance to prove myself
[Music]
interesting okay I like that like Excel
from the adventure
[Music]
what if somebody a document different
story right because that's one's youth I
wanted you to be there take years
run in trouble the mowing bozos up and
start out and it fell faster red tide
shows about anything you can hear them
everything I built all right weapon to
load on where to put a mother fitness
we're going to take everything they got
[Music]
you're not going to stop me
you know into delish
dude I love the beginning part of this
trailers and the whole vlog thing that
made the the International trailer a
like way better for me right here that
made evitable is better for me oh yeah
in that time I'm wondering if like on
the day of Civil War like when they were
filming Civil War they shot that as well
oh yeah were spider-man homecoming as
opposed to oh they went back it so I'm
wondering how they did that oh yeah
actually you know I mean I wouldn't put
it past them to plan far enough
I don't remember with what the
machinations would end of like only
contracting and stuff but I wouldn't be
surprised if it did yeah and I like all
this stuff with Jon Favreau and their
and even like the little touches of it
because it made it look real and tom
hollie can really do all these crazy
splits okay yeah Tom Hall and what part
of what is campaign to be spider-man he
would post videos of him doing actual
like gymnastics moves alright so he can
really do all those lifts and stuff and
I like all the extra footage we got to
Michael Keaton's vulture be a more clear
define thing of what his villain is
doing taking these parts of the Avengers
battles and assembling a massive weapon
makes sense why he's such a like an
important threat I like the aspect more
of Tony Stark's is under estimating
vulture and saying like what someone
else take care of this guy you know yeah
as opposed to and it seems like
spider-man's the only one who's really
focused on we got to take this guy down
or or he's under estimating spider-man
is saying like we got dudes much bigger
than you for this like don't get
yourself hurt you know like yeah stay
down like go do your thing maybe that's
not I'm going to fly this time maybe
spider-man is truly extraordinary and
cannot we can find a neighborhood right
and a whole sequence to when he has a
tie
yeah yeah got a signal how many attitude
oh hey man right I'm home come running
out of the hotel go we [ __ ] we are
you gonna kiss those and dare I
does that you know you think if I'm
gonna have some tongue with India
probably he's gonna touch your nipples I
do not like without a couple of shirts
in the way and you know here's the
general like happens Dan look if I go
add it on the dance floors what I'm
thinking out there none of this film but
I'm loving the tone
I'm loving the tone of the whole thing
of what we're getting it's the one thing
that's making this feel like this can be
unique spider-man experience the only
thing that's really doing it for me back
with Tom Hollands performance Peter
Parker is consistently the thing that
gets me like really excited about this
movie and each of these trailers gave me
even more of that and that's what you
know anchors the story and I'm really
excited to revisit it now I wasn't like
jacked when Amazing Spiderman came out
like I was interested but like now I'm
actually excited again they're updating
it it's going to take me a minute to
kind of process the whole like ah
spider-man suit is like Jarvis they're
really updated the vulture and stuff
like that so I'm interested to see now
what the mechanics of their world
manatees you know oh and the stuff with
spider-man suit kind of be under Tony's
control he's a little limited with the
suit that's why I just sort of seemed
like Peter was tampering with the state
of trying to figure it out but his
friend was Ned was like it's blocked
while these codes I start but yeah
training wheels protic because there's a
cool touch to see all the additions that
the suit has as I was wondering what are
all the real additions that the suit has
a Tony at afore I am seeing that it's
actually kind of you know more sci-fi to
has all these technological advancements
that allow them to see more le more it's
like Batman don't it's like Batman suit
belly yeah exactly
but at the same time it has restrictions
on it Tony controls and it's gonna be a
fair amount of Iron Man in this film I
really I here's only in a few scenes
okay and I'm pretty sure the shredder
showed us all this thing yeah they look
like a few key is as much as this needs
to be its own standalone film and not be
all about connecting to the Avengers it
looks like because spider-man is finally
in the MCU the way that's been the whole
big deal is that spider-man is finally
in it normally when I see all these
Avengers rep
says I can get a little tired of you
know universe building crap when it's
like really in my face especially in
trailers but for spider-man it kind of
doesn't bother me because I'm like we
already got a bunch of solo spider-man
movies written on the MCU I don't mind
if they're going out of their way to
really connect more to be better
remember to the Avengers so an Iron Man
in theirs I still hope that the majority
of it makes it feel like its own
standalone piece I'm ok with all the
references are happening yeah I feel
like they've gotten more natural
overtime with how they incorporate how
they basically make the Avengers world a
pretty big world where you just kind of
hear about the different characters from
time yeah they've gotten more natural at
it well I've just gotten more used to it
but I feel like they're better at it now
oh so where you just kind of accept the
reality and it's a little less hammy
using I love you guys thank you to
everyone from all the crazy countries
are tuning in from thank you for tuning
in for everyone in the States
thank you for tuning in as well whoever
is up with us in those dates is late at
night thank you you're new to the
channel subscribe and also if you
subscribe put down that you subscribe if
it's this video that made you subscribe
put it down talking to you on the
livestream [ __ ] you on the camera put
down an application hook that
notification bill and notify whatever up
videos out John is Det John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram go check out our
patreon for all our exclusive goodies on
there excuse the video content and all
this other awesome rewards much love to
everyone out there thank you for
everyone to tune in to the live stream
and if you didn't get a chance to catch
a live stream I don't blame you it's
1:30 in the morning